FOR THAT FATHER.
A BIZARRE STORY THERE.
>> Dana: BREAKING MOMENTS AGO
THE COMMERCE DEPARTMENT
ANNOUNCED THE ECONOMY GREW BY
2.6% IN THE THIRD QUARTER
SLIGHTLY BETTER THAN EXPECTED.
THE REBOUND COMES AFTER TWO
CONSECUTIVE QUARTERS OF NEGATIVE
GROWTH BUT SIGNS THE ECONOMY IS
STILL IN TROUBLE.
WHAT ARE THEY?
MARIA BARTIROMO JOINS US NOW
FROM FOX BUSINESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
TELL US WHAT DO WE NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THIS?
>> ISN’T IT NICE TO SEE GROWTH
AFTER TWO CONSECUTIVE QUARTERS
OF CONTRACTION, IT IS NICE TO
SEE GROWTH BUT I AM UNIMPRESSED
WITH THE NUMBERS.
THE GAIN IN THE GDP THIS QUARTER
IS DUE TO TRADE AND GOVERNMENT
SPENDING.
LET’S ALSO NOT FORGET THE
READING IS JULY, AUGUST AND
SEPTEMBER.
SO IT IS SOMEWHAT BACKWARDS
LOOKING.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DURABLE GOODS
NUMBER TODAY, THAT IS SALES OF
ITEMS THAT ARE MEANT TO LAST 6
TO 9 MONTHS DOWN THE ROAD.
THAT WAS WEAKER THAN EXPECTED.
IN MY OPINION THAT’S A MUCH MORE
ACCURATE READ OF WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW.
YOU HAVE A GDP BETTER THAN
EXPECTED BUT LARGELY BECAUSE OF
TRADE.
EXPORTS IN THE QUARTER WERE UP
WHILE IMPORTS WERE DOWN.
EXPORTS OUT GREW IMPORTS IS THE
POINT DUE TO EXPORTS OF
INDUSTRIAL SUPPLIES, MATERIALS
AND WAIT FOR IT, PETROLEUM
PRODUCTS.
>> Bill: WE WERE TALKING BEFORE
THE SHOW.
CAN YOU MAKE THE ARGUMENT THAT
WE’RE NOT IN A RECESSION NOW?
WE BROKE THE STRING OF
CONSECUTIVE QUARTERS.
>> WELL YES, BECAUSE YOU ARE
SEEING GROWTH.
IT IS THE FIRST READING OF THE
GGDP.
WE’LL GET MORE READINGS COMING
OUT BUT ALL EXPECTATIONS ARE
WE’RE DOING A DOUBLE DIP
RECESSION.
THAT WE WERE IN RECESSION TWO
QUARTERS EARLIER IN THE YEAR.
WE HAVE GROWTH THIS QUARTER BUT
IN 2023 THE RECESSION RETURNS.
I DON’T THINK ANYBODY IS
EXPECTING WE HAD CONTRACTION AND
IT’S OVER.
NO, WE’RE EXPECTING A SEVERE
RECESSION IN 2023.
WE WILL NOW PROBABLY EXPECT A
DOUBLE DIP RECESSION IS WHAT
THEY CALL IT.
THE ECB RAISED INTEREST RATES 75
BASIS POINTS LIKE THE FED.
THE NEXT FED MEETING IS NEXT
WEEK NOVEMBER 1ST AND TWO.
EXPECTING ANOTHER 75 BASIS
POINTS.
EVERYTHING IS MORE EXPENSIVE
INCLUDING BORROWING COST.
>> Dana: CAN COMPANIES BREATHE A
SIGN OF RELIEF OR LAYOFFS ARE
COMING?
>> THE JOB NUMBERS WILL CATCH UP
TO A SLOWING ECONOMY.
WE HEAR IT FROM CEOs NOW.
WE’RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THIRD
QUARTER SEASON WE’RE NOT GETTING
GOOD GUIDANCE.
THE JOB NUMBERS WILL CATCH UP
WITH THE RECESSIONARY NUMBERS
AND WE’LL SEE THOSE NUMBERS
CHANGE IN A BIG WAY IN THE
COMING MONTHS.
>> Bill: BACK TO YOUR SUGGESTION
ABOUT PETROLEUM, OIL, GAS PRICES
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT ON THAT.
PAINTS A ROSIE PICTURE OF SORTS.
>> President Biden: GAS PRICES
ARE CONTINUING TO GO DOWN.
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING DOWN
WE’RE MAKING SERIOUS PROGRESS IN
GETTING PRICES CLOSE TO WHAT
THEY WERE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC.
>> Bill: OKAY.
SO $3.76 A GALLON TODAY.
FEBRUARY OF 2020, $2.45.
>> AND STILL MUCH HIGHER THAN
WHERE WE WERE WHEN JOE BIDEN
FIRST ENTERED THE OVAL OFFICE, I
WOULD POINT OUT.
GASOLINE PRICES HAVE BEEN
PRESSURED LOWER BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT IS SELLING OIL FROM
THE STRATEGIC OIL RESERVE.
AND THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS
MOVE.
THAT’S NOT AN ENERGY POLICY.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE TO ME HOW
MANY IMPLICATIONS WE’VE SEEN AS
A RESULT OF THE ENERGY POLICY
OUT OF THIS ADMINISTRATION.
THE FAILURE TO DEAL WITH THE
DRILLERS IN AMERICA AND FAILURE
TO ENCOURAGE FOSSIL FUEL
COMPANIES AND OIL COMPANIES TO
DO PRODUCTION.
IT’S JUST NOT HAPPENING.
>> Dana: WE HAD MATT GORMAN
TALKING ABOUT HEATING COSTS IN
THE NORTHEAST AND THEY ARE
FEELING IT.
PART OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR BOLDUC
UP IN NEW HAMPSHIRE RUNNING FOR
SENATE.
ZBLOOTS ING A BIG DEAL.
WE’LL SEE HEATING COSTS CONTINUE
TO RISE.
IT IS ALSO A SUPPLY/DEMAND
SITUATION.
ALSO INDIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
ENERGY POLL CISMD WE ARE ALSO
TALKING ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR
BLACK-OUTS.
NOT A GOOD STORY.
HE CAN TALK ABOUT GASOLINE
PRICES LOOKING BETTER BUT THEY
ARE STILL MUCH HIGHER THAN WHEN
HE WALKED INTO OFFICE AND ALSO
LARGELY THE RESULT OF THESE
MANUFACTURED MOVES LIKE SELLING
OIL FROM THE STRATEGIC.
>> Bill: WE’LL TALK TO A MOTHER
AND DAUGHTER TRYING TO NAVIGATE
THESE WATERS NEXT HOUR.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IS TELLING
YOU WHAT RIGHT NOW?
>> IT’S TELLING US WE’RE ALL
WORRIED.
MANY PEOPLE ARE LIVING PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT WHEN YOU
SEE THAT YOUR WAGES ARE UP 5%
BUT THE PRICE OF GOODS IS UP
8 1/2%.
THE STUFF THAT WE’RE BUYING
EGGS, MEAT, BREAD, ETC.  WENT UP
MUCH MORE THAN 8.2%.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE FEELING IT
AND CUTTING INTO THEIR WAGES AND
WHY WE HAVE SUCH DIRE
PREDICTIONS.
>> Dana: LAWRENCE JONES WAS IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
ONE LADY SAID SOME PEOPLE ARE
LIVING DAY-TO-DAY, NOT JUST